you know every morning when I wake up
and before my husband leaves the house I
get on my knees and I suck some love
into that man because I know when he
goes out there there's going to be
Temptations and negativity I want him to
start the day on a good note
so don't want to come over today but I
got to welcome back to the three Muslims
we've been getting a lot of DMS to
respond to this sister and without
further Ado let's go ahead in you know
every morning when I wake up and before
my husband leaves the house I get on my
knees and I suck some love into that man
because I know when he goes out there
there's going to be Temptations and
negativity I want him to start the day
on a good note and the days that he's
not with me and he's with his other wife
I know he's taken care of so if you want
to learn how to take care of your man go
get my book how to have fun like a pro
when your husband comes out of the
shower get on your knees and suck some
positivity into that men then go sit him
down turn on the TV and give him
something to eat hop in the shower and
come back and give him some dessert too
many women complain to me and they're
like he never lasts long enough
now he will and try it and if you really
want to learn more go get my book how to
have fun like a pro it'll give you
things you've never heard of before and
you'll have a happier healthier intimate
life a lot of men love saying that when
a woman cheats it's much
we're gonna we're gonna put on pause
right there before she uh embarrasses
the Oma more
bro who is the most pro-intimacy
Pro education Channel
when it comes to Muslim YouTube that's
us bro
we love talking about intimacy from an
academic point of view we brought in
Specialists right
but there's there's a difference between
having Haya
and then being Shameless so what do you
guys think about this
subhanallah you know someone actually DM
me on Tick Tock one of her videos saying
you know you need to respond to this and
my initial thought was she's and it
wasn't one of this these videos was a
different video it was less explicit and
um even then I could tell she's just
trying to sell something
and um it's very clear she's just trying
to plug her book I think she's she's not
really counting on women listening to
that but she's more so accounting on men
listening to it buying getting giving it
to their wives or something weird like
that stuff she's really big on playing
on the insecurity of of men and
um
I don't know what's up with her like any
like you mentioned there's nothing wrong
with talking about these things very
generally or very modestly
but to make a 60 second tick tock on
it's a kids app
saying you got on your knees stuck with
all the themes like you don't need to
describe it bro you don't need to
describe it
um so I really think she's just trying
to appeal to men when she says these
things because women don't really
respond well to that there's a Hadith
where the Prophet saws much in the the
most wicked among the people in the eye
of Allah on the day of judgment are
going to be the men who go to their
wives or she comes to him
and then he divulges her secret bro and
vice versa supplies for women too it's
by Muslim 1437 so just thinking about
this from an Islamic point of view right
if this was something permissible
it would have been a tradition right we
would have been openly talking about
these things not that we weren't openly
talking but there's a difference between
making a general point to teach someone
and just hearing your your personal
business bro about your intimate affairs
uh I'm not going to say much man
all I know is uh
imagine we would have
imagery would have seen this video that
when we first started and we were
legitimately the three Giants
there's a there's a verse from the Quran
that I wanted to share as well before we
resume the video but it's in Surah
al-baqarah it's a 187th verse it
basically says that the righteous women
are devoutly obedient and guard in the
husband's absence what Allah would have
them guard this is this is key bro
because imagine this bro imagine that
like I don't know why this is just a
normal thing now but people are talking
about their personal affairs with their
friends with their colleagues for no
reason there's a difference between
nasiha
and just being like hey girl guess what
my man did yesterday and then you just
go deep into details bro and the the
friend has more details and has a better
picture of you than subhanallah your
your own friends like that shouldn't be
the case bro no one should know you know
what I mean and like Allah the way Allah
describes US are as if we're like
garments bro we're close on One Another
We're supposed to conceal one another
we're supposed to have Haya and shyness
not that we're just supposed to be open
about this bro this is this is stuff
that in like gym locker rooms bro go far
world you know they're like oh this is
what happened with this chick last night
you know what I mean it's just ego and
it's just unnecessary if you really
think about this man she the one doesn't
have a husband if she's speaking like
this or two
she has a husband and he has no Creator
whatsoever this is where I was gonna
I'll tell you this bro when we continue
this you're gonna see she has a man and
not only does she have a man
he's the one filming these videos and
he's behind the scenes because you'll
hear him now and what so bothersome is
not only does he not and he's the most
daiute guy that I probably know of
Miller protect us all from that but he's
the one actually facilitating these
things bro he's the ones actually
recording these videos asking her these
prompting questions so
let's take a look at that bro are you
sure this is not some pay you dude
listen we'll we'll talk about that at
the end bro because I have a conspiracy
theory all right
a lot of men love saying that when a
woman cheats it's much worse than when a
man cheats because when a woman cheats
she's building an emotional connection
it's premeditated all of that whereas
when a man cheats it's just physical
that's not true it is just physical
though no
a lot of times when a man cheats it's
just because they saw a lady the lady
was attractive one thing led to another
and boom it happened it can we can say
the same for a woman a woman can see a
man one thing leads to another boom it
happens not on average though that's the
thing that's why you see a lot of times
when a man and a woman has friends they
become friends with benefits a lot of
times more likely than not it's the
woman that ends up falling for the guy
and ends up ruining that whole friends
with benefit relationship because their
emotions got to the best of them maybe
like sometimes like in the year 2000
maybe back in the day but in today's day
and age is a lot of men that are more
emotionally in touch with their emotions
there's lots of women that are more
and also with their physical size it's
not like what it used to be people I
feel like when you have sex you're
sharing energies it's easy for anyone to
fall into it whether it's a man or a
woman okay but I'm not talking about the
act of it I'm talking about what leads
to it and that's why men say it's worse
when women cheat because they're talking
about what leads to it they're talking
about the three months of texting that
led to the lady doing what she did
they're talking about the lion to to her
man that led to what happened they're
not talking about like something just
happened in one day I'll tell you what
they're talking about when a man says
the woman cheating is worse it's because
Society first of all holds women to a
higher standard than it holds men and it
punishes women for the same mistakes
that men make worse and on top of that
men love to say look at the women
because they don't want to hold any
accountability for the fact that they
cheated the reality is cheating is bad
whether you're a man or a woman and if
you're a man take responsibility don't
try to put it on the woman like oh if
you cheated it's worse than if I cheat
no you shouldn't cheat at all that's not
an excuse if your wife cheats on you
same same way men love to say if I cheat
on my woman there was a reason
if your wife had three months to build a
relationship with someone outside of
your marriage where were you
where were you like you could have
stopped the premeditation yo cut this
damn video please listen I gotta tell
you something like this is this is going
to be very important all right
she said under no circumstances cheating
okay right
simultaneously this delusional sister
says but then where were you those three
months
so she's anti-cheating and I swear to
God that wallahi there's another video I
didn't put this in this compilation she
clearly said that someone asked her a
question right my my husband cheated on
me with this other woman right with this
other sister do you know the advice she
gave bro because she's apparently like a
marriage counselor she said that's fine
just tell him to marry that woman that
he cheated on with and that way he saved
two people from Haram the woman that he
cheated on with and himself
like do you do you realize this bro it's
delusional
stuff
All I'm gonna say
for these people clearly
anyone in the racer mind can see that
this is
a
it's a scam bro
it's so fake
and Sophie wallahi is so fake y'all can
see it from a mile away and if you can't
man you really gotta check yourself and
you shouldn't be on the internet you
can't see all fate this is like it's so
genuinely fake that I couldn't even
watch it I had to tell you to turn it
off and this isn't even me trying to
like uh do anything for high value
because y'all know like I'm not the one
to like do extra stuff just for high
value but it's like bro like a woman
speaking like this a man having
literally zero data and look and if it
is real bro if it is real
damn
that's all I gotta say bro
let me know look at us can you imagine
any wife of yours
just being this open bro in a video that
you filmed Forget You filmed in any
video bro can you just imagine that bro
that is literally the most emasculating
thing ever bro just imagine the eyes of
Allah how much is anger and Allah bro
like subhanallah bro
is there is there another Clipper is
that there's not this one
no please don't blame it you know so
let's be real have you ever had sex yes
oh my God why are Muslims so weird about
talking about sex
because when you're young
they'll talk about sex don't look at
boys don't talk to boys don't look at
girls don't talk to girls and it's like
a like they don't even say sex is Haram
they say don't talk to the other gender
and so like there's no sexual education
at all and I think sex in marriage is
not Haram obviously it's before marriage
that it's like I'm just gonna pause that
real quick yeah you don't need to talk
to the other gender
or the other sex I don't know what other
gender is but you don't need to talk
about sex to learn about intimacy
education you really don't I didn't
learn from the other gender or sex Rami
and Anna I'm sure you didn't you can
learn from your shifts you can learn
from people in your community fathers
that should be teaching their kids that
you know it's you don't need to talk to
women to understand these things
yeah I I find some things come with them
they always present this kind of weird
false dichotomy like even in the last
clip you know they I think they made
that video for the sake of making a
discussion and bringing popularity to
their page because think about it the
guys are going to agree with the guy and
the girl is gonna or you know the girls
are gonna agree with the girl then it's
just it's supposed to spark some kind of
um publicity for them I genuinely
believe that they definitely staged that
or planned it beforehand and this one as
well it's a weird dichotomy either you
talk with the other gender and therefore
you need to learn how to talk talk to
other gender and all that stuff and you
buy her course and you buy her book her
basically you don't know anything and
and you're basically misguided it's it's
a very weird dichotomy and it's very
clear they're just trying to sell a
course and a little note on both of them
they're both comedians by the way they
are both comedians so what if this whole
thing is just a stunt I mean I I hate to
bring it up and maybe they repented so I
won't mention their names but there was
a family before
you know a brother who did Rokia his
wife was a nakabi and they're living a
complete double life they scammed the
Muslims out of maybe hundreds of
thousands of pounds and all this stuff
and they looked so genuine so pure so
clean and then just like that they're
exposed you know subhanallah for all
this crazy stuff may Allah protect us
from that so yeah if if this couple who
we can clearly see has very you know
clear problems in their beliefs and
their practices and their statements and
what they're doing online
um and it seems like they're just
selling a course and I wouldn't be
surprised these people are barely even
Muslim are rarely practicing to begin
with and just trying to sell reports
about intimacy
I agree bro I wanted to touch on the
point of a female promiscuity from
earlier and what I'm going to say right
now is not to go against Islamic and
rulings on punishments on adultery
that's not what I'm talking about right
but where she was saying oh it's if men
and women cheat it's the same listen
if men and women cheat it's the same
okay sure like it's cheating as a in
Islam and eyes of Allah it's not okay
right if you cheat on your wife versus
you if you cheat on your husband it's
the same thing
however the point I'm sure that he and a
lot of men that have I guess coined that
term or that phrase that she was
bothered by is we're talking about
promiscuity bro at the end of the day
like a man has the ability to be
poligenous in a permissible way for sure
right there's impermissible way to be
poligenous but I'm saying it is possible
that if he wants to be with multiple
women at the same time not
simultaneously like in that moment but
you know what I mean if he wants to do
this bro there is a permissible means of
navigating male promiscuity in halal
but the problem is for women there is
none do you get what I mean like she
cannot simultaneously be with multiple
men so if she cheats that female
promiscuity in no way is it allowed do
you know what I mean but I also want to
make it clear again that I'm not saying
cheating is okay regardless it's not but
I'm saying female promise cutie is not
the same as male promiscuity
yeah but it's it's it is a bigger
discussion for sure
um definitely we should we should do
like an episode with Gabriel on that
yeah inshallah and uh the last clip oh
no and I think there needs to be a
healthier approach to how we talk to our
kids about it especially in today's day
and age especially if you're in the west
but even if you're in the east
the internet has made it accessible to
everyone so if you don't want your kids
learning the wrong stuff you need to be
able to talk to them about it first and
that way you can kind of Monitor and
manage how they get their information
and how they move forward with it so sex
isn't bad sex isn't head-on sex is great
in a marriage sex is healthy for a
marriage the way we talk about it needs
to change
and that is why you're not hanging
around my daughter's sister's Auntie's
uncle's grandma
I'm laughing because they're still gonna
be so
something I don't want to say anything
but there's gonna be some person in the
comment that's gonna judge you as if as
if they're perfect as if they've never
sinned in their life as if the things
you're saying isn't factual in truth you
know what I read somewhere that it said
take your advice from people in the
arena not people who paid for the cheap
seats
so hey I gave birth in Phoenix when I
went to the hospital the nurse asked me
what race are you I was like this is a
trick question everybody knows the best
race to be in the hospital is white
so I said white
do you have a religious preference
Caucasian
your emergency contact my husband his
name
okay you got me I'm Arab
this is the part where we're supposed to
laugh
like marriage is halal I like the name
but whatever they're doing that's not do
you know what I mean it's it's
disgusting bro and I really hope that
people don't think that we're here
trying to you know pull other people
down because everyone has an intention
do you get what I mean maybe maybe it's
possible they have the intention of
spreading proper intimacy discussions
talking about this and
having just good intentions for people
for the Oma maybe but the way that
they're going about this it's it's not
okay bro it literally is not okay
there's nothing that you could do to
justify this bro
yeah 100 so what what is the correct way
to go about you know having these
discussions and even if someone did want
to sell a course you know there's
nothing wrong with that but what would
be the correct way you know in going
about that
I would say bro first and foremost we
should have some higher in talking about
our own personal affairs so it's better
to refer to things specifically from
Quran and Sunnah if possible
um you can bring up academic studies and
discussions you can say even in
principality you don't have to mention
this is what I do this is what my wife
does or vice versa this is what my
husband does for his sister saying that
it just it it removes a little bit of
Purity from you as a Muslim and then
when you do that in front of a camera it
removes Purity from the ummah because
the ummah is what's watching your videos
emulating the the thought process that
you have a lot of younger women don't
know any better so now they're going to
see this video and they're going to be a
little bit more loose in discussion with
their friends right
um and you could just see how it's going
to be a slippery slope when you look at
the prophet Islam he was very direct
when it came to intimacy discussions
right and I think it's it's a phenomenal
model because in a lot of different
religions and cultural practices you see
that it's a taboo topic this is not a
taboo Topic in Islam whatsoever we're
very Pro intimacy education but there's
a way to go around it with a little bit
of shyness and dignity
yeah 100 100
what about you
I mean just imagine she has a daughter
or even the Sun and and they run across
this video
imagine uh the daughter or the son's
friends
know about this video of their mother
and their mother speaking like this
so I it goes back to what I said man
see Allah these people men they got to
feel a lot and they really gotta think
twice about these things I speak for
them they gotta think more than twice to
be honest
but it's like man we're all going to
answer to Allah it's like do you really
want to answer to Allah Allah is going
to ask you like oh
you supposedly wanted to help people out
here with this uh Pursuit that you did
and the way that you did it you
basically were saying oh
um I'm gonna suck some love into my man
bro how ashamed would you be
if Allah was in front of you and was
just presenting that to you he's like
what do you have to say to this
so again let's see our love man these
people man they just
I don't know what they're thinking to be
honest
type and I think what about you
I think that about sums it up to be
honest there I think you know we'd be
beating a dead horse if we kept going at
it unless we got the point across it's
very clear
follow us
and with that being said guys comment
down below if you made it this far
actual intimacy discussions you would
like to hear from us because there's a
way that we should do it and
alhamdulillah I think we don't we did
the best of our abilities from day one
whenever we talk about intimacy we try
to give these disclaimers we try to give
you know what I mean we don't try to
sensationalize it with shock factor and
the first thing we say go down on your
knee like no none of this bro I think
that there's a there's a very Islamic
way of going about it with etiquette and
manners and I think that you know may
Allah allow us to all have that if we
are going to be talking about intimacy
because it's not a light topic bro it's
not something that you just do you look
like
bless him anytime he talks about
sensitive topics not only is there an
actual like written disclaimer in the
beginning of the video he then also
gives a verbal disclaimer before the
khutba and then multiple times he he
tries to make it known how sensitive and
serious topic it is he doesn't just do
any of this I can't imagine anyone like
him or Gabriel doing anything like that
bro so inshallah that being said guys
foreign